Ukrainian officials see most of chiefs
power supply has been restored one day
after a Russian missile barrage in
what's become a common tactic since the
fall Russia targeted Ukraine's
infrastructure with long-range Rockets
the apparent aim is to weaken the
resolve of ukrainians some ukrainians
are turning to the Arts as a form of
defiance to Russia's Invasion MTS tayab
shows us how the dancers of Ukraine's
National Ballet are trying to keep the
spirit of their embattled country alive
[Music]
they are the front line cranes fight to
preserve its cultural heritage
armed with pirouettes Plies and chites
in a battle of survival for an art form
they've dedicated their lives to
like Olga kifiak Von Kramer La Prima
ballerina at the Ukraine National Ballet
one of the country's most celebrated
performers
Ukraine is still at War you're still
dancing why is it so important to still
dance
we want the world to see that Ukraine
also has its own incredible culture she
says that's why we continue to dance we
dance in spite of Russia
ballet has long been one of moscow's
most revered cultural exports but
several of its most acclaimed answers
were either from or trained in Ukraine
When Vladimir Putin launched his
invasion one year ago the curtain went
down on stages across the country
leading some Ukrainian performers to
pick up arms and join the fight
including Alexander shopoval he was the
principal dancer at the Ukraine National
Ballet a once in a generation Talent who
over the course of 28 Seasons performed
in 30 different roles
but he will never dance again in
September the 48 year old father of two
was killed in a Russian mortar attack
his funeral was televised on Ukrainian
State TV where he was remembered as a
courageous romantic
for Makita sukarugov chapoval was a
mentor and friend he's now taken over
his role as the company's principal
dancer a role sukurukov feels the weight
of
how did you feel when you learned
Alexander died
um
it was very difficult for I think for
all company it was very difficult it
really brought the war here
back to this company yep
yep
but here at the national Opera theater
in Kiev
for a brief moment in time audiences are
transfixed by dazzling performances on
stage
tonight it's the classic Don Quixote a
romantic comedy for the ages with
sukarukov starring in the lead role
a performance attended by American page
VN originally from Seattle she now works
as a volunteer in key so supporting the
arts for you is really an act of
defiance to Russia's aggression yeah I
mean I think a lot of people back home
when I came they asked me if Kiev was
destroyed and I said absolutely not you
know it's it's not destroyed and to
continue on is really the Ukrainian
spirit it's really incredible to see
that
people continuing to just not exist but
live
but so many lives continue to be lost
including kipyak Von Kramer's brother
who died fighting in eastern Ukraine in
August still she says nothing will stop
her from performing
yes it's hard she says but we are
ukrainians we are unbreakable
an unbreakable Spirit on the front lines
and on stage
for CBS Saturday morning imtia's tired
key Ukraine
it's what you can control right they
can't control what's happening in the
front lines but they can do the best
they can up on stage and communicate in
that way it's a great to their country
people I love what one woman said there
it's not just it's not just that they're
existing but they're living as well